The answer is 1965- 7-14. Here's how we would calculate this using Java
Objects. We would create a Day object and specify the year, month and day as
November 28th, 1964. If we use the two string method. Shows us what's in this
Day object right now, which is exactly what we entered. November 18th, 1964.
And then we can add days. That's the flight time. And now, this object has July
14th, 1965. So that's the arrival date. As a side note, this format is an
international standard called ISO 8601. It was chosen for good computer science
reasons. There needed to be a standard form used by all the different countries
so that data stored in computers could be transferred across borders. They put
the year first so that when you sort a date sort of alphabetically or
lexicographically, don't have to know that word, it's okay. The dates will show
up in chronological order.